salut ça va
ouais moi aussi ça va ça va bon moi dans
ted
je suis le et le dge de 2entertain il ya
plusieurs façons de communiquer dans la
vie par exemple il ya les expressions
faciales
il ya internet il ya il ya plein de
choses via les messages parler le
langage et notamment dans le langage
nous on a un langage formulé avec des
démos des voyelles il ya des consonnes
il ya des voyelles des années odieux et
il fait un temps où il y avait une tribu
alors je ne sais plus du tout d'où est
ce qu elle vient d attribuer tout ce que
je sais c'est qu'ils avaient une tribu
et il parlait pas il faisait juste des
bruits des claquements demander des
trucs bizarres comme ça et est en fait
ça s'appelle le beatbox pour moi c'est
un langage c'est mon langage à moi et
j'aimerais bien parler cette langue avec
vous si vous voulez bien
ouais merci
alors je vais en faire un petit peu
petit peu et après je vais essayer de
vous apprendre à en faire parce que vous
êtes chaud ouais cool c'est cool oui
aussi un peu choix je suis d'accord
alors est ce que vous savez prononcé
chat écho dans chaud etc a joué qu'à ça
c'est bien chaud wesh au cas ok alors là
dedans il ya des voyelles alors d'abord
on va faire chaud chaud cache-cache au
cachot cas pas mal
maintenant on enlève les voyais n est
pas mal
le résultat final ça est ce que vous
pensez qu'on peut y arriver
bon moi je pense que si bon il faut
centrer un petit peu un peut-être que là
dedans grâce à la il ya des boxeurs de
talent qui voit arriver peut-être mais
de me dépasser pas je vais me sentir mal
après on restait un petit coup ouais bah
là plutôt cool non
bon je vous laisserai vous entraînez de
chez vous un devant le miroir ayez pas
peur de la tête que vous faites quand
vous faites du beatbox là vous voyez pas
jeunes micro devant la bouche mais en
vrai ça ressemble un peu à ça n'a l'air
de rien franchement ben c'est pas grave
c'est cool c'est marrant janssen en fait
un petit peu plus
il ya plus que ça dans bebo ici et là et
la batterie donc on peut faire du jazz
du hip hop des trucs comme ça genre
merci et après on peut rajouter des fois
des grosses boîtes à bonbons aux propos
propres au bon moment
merci merci oui maintenant je vais faire
n'importe quoi
merci ça c'est cool d'être sur scène ça
fait battre mon coeur
waouh c'est le bruit de mon coeur c'est
un coeur hip hop bayer fait des idéaux
c'est bizarre c'est grâce à vous je
complimente un peu qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre
y'a pas de bruit dans la vie de boxe ça
que ça on peut toujours là depuis le
début je savais même pas ce que j'allais
faire sur scène en entrant j'avais prévu
un petit texte et je suis passé à côté
et je sais pas j'aime bien ce truc là
est ce que vous aimez bien communiquer
comme ça avec les gens genre vous
arrivez dans la rue vous voyez quelqu'un
vous faites bonjour tu as bien non ok tu
te rencontrer ben là je suis en train de
vous rencontrer et je parle avec vous à
ma façon
donc je sais pas c'est quelque chose de
bien c'est l'art comme telle heure on a
parlé des artistes pour créer un nouveau
monde
peut-être que je pourrai faire partie de
ce nouveau monde on sait pas ou pas on
verra
bon j'arrête de parler je fais de la vie
d'autrefois
merci bon j'ai plus grand chose à
montrer au revoir merci à vous merci
beaucoup
alors